yes doc thank you yeah I help you but I
am 68 years old my height is 53 and
wanting to do pound and happen um
Jamaica for the past four years I come
here but the weather has affected my
breathing and I had a dad from damaged
when I was a child so there is
constriction to me my lung
so I'm not able to breathe properly but
recently I went to the doctor and they
realized that my oxygen level was very
low so they trying to put me on oxygen
to get my system working but is there
anything I can do to be able to come off
the oxygen yes you say wait a minute you
say you're 162 pounds yes okay do you
have any skin problems any eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis no no any bowel
pones
constipation diarrhea irritable bowel
syndrome appendicitis anything like that
you know give children yes yes the
people yes now Danny them have any
respiratory problems or skin problems no
they know but they never know no okay
okay you weigh 160 - yeah okay so sure
me what would you do for her for a diet
and what would you do for her as a
supplement program to support healthy
breathing's so we can get her blood
oxygen levels up well for those issues
personally what I would get her on again
is probably - she's on the cusp a
healthy brain and her packs and then I
would add the oxy body to that okay what
kind of dad would you put her on a
gluten-free diet no wheat barley rye
oats you're exactly right because she'd
have this breathing problem for a long
time okay and so definitely you need to
go Faye on a free diet and no fried
foods no processed meats no oils or
glutens no wheat bread around
oats when I say no oils means no olive
oil coconut oil margins mayonnaise house
including oils and of course it is 162
pounds you should take
to healthier Boehner hard-packed a month
bulldozer thing twice a day and has to
support all of your physiological
functions of your body these are the
basic requirements then specifically to
to help support your body's need for
more oxygen to help raise the oxygen
level in the blood
char's exactly correct the oxy body and
go ahead and take an ounce to that 30
minutes for each meal that would be
three quarts of the oxy body per month
if it's a financial problem I wouldn't
go any lower than two quarts per month
so you have one house before breakfast
and a half hour before breakfast one out
for dinner but ideally you would have an
ounce a half hour before each meal okay
and it's imperative to take those two
healthy brain or heart packs for months
again if it's a price issue you can take
one but you're going to have to get
extra or the FAS and the FA plus it so
you can take three EFA is twice a day
and three I think plusses place today
wouldn't hurt to throw in which of the
good herbs products would you hear
Tatian Charmaine they must have a
respiratory one I got a healthy London
support healthy lungs supported okay
healthy lungs support and you can get
two bottles of that and take a dose of
the good herbs healthy lung support
twice a day and again give us a call
every couple of weeks you can start the
diet immediately and of course it'll
take maybe three to five days to get the
product from the west coast to Michigan
and particularly Flint Michigan which is
on the east side of the state and then
of course it'll be useful to you might
even ask me to put the order in just
shipped out of Memphis Tennessee which
envenom be just a couple of days to get
the product but you can start to die
immediately
so you can hang up here and give us a
call every two weeks and we'll walk you
through this